this video is made possible by Nord VP M
here you are browsing YouTube that's
pretty safe but shopping online can be
risky those stories you hear of people
having their data stolen it does happen
that is of course unless you protect
yourself with a VPN if you ever use
public Wi-Fi spots you should always
have naud VPN just running in the
background
keeping your safe or maybe you just want
to watch some TV or some other geo
restricted content that isn't available
when you're in another country well Nord
VPN allow you to fix that to you just
click the country you want to appear in
and boom Wow there you are indeed Nord
VPN is the only VPN to get a perfect
score from PC Mag so start protecting
your internet experience today with 70%
off a three year plan plus a month for
free by using the code biographic s-- at
Nord VPN comm forward slash buyer
graphics and let's get into it now I
know here are by graphics we're not
covering them in chronological order but
one at a time we are covering the most
interesting ones and yes of course I'm
talking about Roman emperors Roman
emperors we're men who wielded immense
power in a wide variety of ways some
were good military leaders some ruled
fairly and openly to the benefit of
their citizens some were a destructive
force at the center of plots
conspiracies and murder
today's protagonist what he was all of
the above in many ways he was a puzzling
man he was not born to become an emperor
and when he did become one he appeared
reluctance and spent almost half his
reign and self-imposed exile this is the
story of Tiberius a second Roman Emperor
Tiberius Julius Caesar was born on
November the 16th in the year 42 BCE
this was two years after the
assassination of Julius Caesar and young
Tiberius his childhood would carry on
under the shadow of the civil war that
followed as his father's name was
Tiberius Claudius Nero and his mother
was called Olivia Drusilla Tiberius
senior had been an officer and a Julius
Caesar but had sided with Mark Antony
for this reason the young family lived
in exile constantly in fear of having
their hands tongues or the body parts
handed back to them by Caesar Augustus
the historian Suetonius renowned for his
prose and his body odor wrote this of
Tiberius as early years his childhood
and youth were beset with hardships and
difficulties because narrow and Livia
took him wherever they went in their
flight from Augustus for example when
the family was hiding in Naples
Octavian's men broke into the city and
they had to make a quiet escape through
the port
but the infant Tiberius he cried so
loudly that he nearly betrayed the whole
party often Naples the family moved to
Sicily and eventually to Sparta but or
Gustus he still would not let go and
during a nighttime escape Livia scorched
her hair while running through a forest
fire bucket Eva the toddler when he
turns three or Gustus proclaimed amnesty
for all the conspirators the family
returned to Rome in 39 BCE upon which
Livia took a leaf from her husband's
book and pulled a switcheroo she
divorced Tiberius narrow and set her
eyes on a new husband that could grant a
rosy future for her and her son and for
all Gustus three months after their
marriage Livia delivered another son
Drusus if for a moment he thought the
father was Octavian that would make
Livia a porcupine the gestation period
bottom line is under in 12 days and
dresses a premature baby porcupine
Tiberius his baby brother had in fact
been conceived with Tiberius senior this
is important Livia had no children with
Octavian which meant that she had to
work extra hard to secure the
advancement of her sons in point of fact
Octavian Augustus had been preparing for
his own two grandsons Gaius Caesar and
Lucius Caesar to succeed him Gaius and
Lucius were the sons of Augustus's
daughter Julia and Augustus's right-hand
man Marcus Agrippa even though the
parents of the two boys were alive and
kicking or Gustus had decided to adopt
them to their to groom them
for succession a common practice at that
time Livia's efforts to supplant the
order of succession seemed to pay
dividends in his early adolescence
Tiberius had the privilege to organize
some gladiatorial games in the forum
more importantly was allowed to ride on
Augustus's chariot at his tram following
the Battle of Actium at age 18 Tiberias
was appointed Questor an entry-level
magistrate with the responsibility of
collecting taxes or even recruiting
soldiers in conquered territories his
skill and energy it soon led to a
military command
[Music]
in the 22 BC a twenty-year-old Tiberius
was dispatched to Iberia as a tribunal
attic hobbies' an officer who served as
second in command to the legatus the
head of the Legion in this function he
served in the northern region of
Cantabria the locals had rebelled
against Rome and Tiberius restored peace
by decimating them this success in Spain
granted him a more prestigious
assignment Tiberius was now put at the
head of a legions sent to Armenia in 20
BC to install a king friendly to Rome
the neighbouring path Ian's who would be
modern-day Iranian 's were not amused
and threatened war Tiberius displayed
some good negotiating skills agreeing to
a compromise a neutral King would rule
Armenia making it a buffer state between
Rome and Parthia in exchange the
Parthian x' would return three legionary
battle standards seized from marcus
crassus at the Battle of kaho Tiberias
returns a room with three Eagles and was
hailed as a hero in 19 BCE Tiberius
married his first wife that say Nia whom
he loved dearly and I realized by
calling her his first wife we sort of
just spoiled what's about to come next
according to Suetonius visalia was the
daughter of Marcus Agrippa and who was a
Griffith wife well Julia that's daughter
of Gustus all right so I've done a
little bit of maths for you Julia was
born in 39 BC and she married a gripper
in 21 BC she was age 18 so far so good
Agrippa died in the year 12 BC in those
nine years they were married and these
two would have a total of five children
with one of them being that Sonya based
on this timeline that Sonya - when she
married Tiberius Suetonius does not
offer clarity so I'm going to assume and
hope that that Sonya was a daughter from
a previous marriage and that the name
just ran in the family another name that
ran in the family was drusus Tiberius
his brother when the newlyweds had a son
they two names their child Drusus
because I mean why Jews a new name and
miss a chance to complicate a historians
work but what historians do get right as
the military campaigns we do know that
Tiberius is military adventures
continued in 15 BC when he joins little
brother drusus in Gore as Suetonius
described it the long-haired province
here are feuds between
Gaelic chieftains and
considerable unrest but Tiberius brought
his own brand of Iberian peace after
that he fought in the Alps Austria and
Germany during these campaigns he
ensured that the local population bends
the knee to Rome securing the northern
borders of the empire during his
campaign in Germany he captured some
40,000 German prisoners whom he forcibly
relocated in Gaul to put an end to their
constant revolts eight centuries later
Charmaine would supply the exact same
tactic to quash the Saxons all the while
mother Livia had continued her nationai
shion's to ensure the career progression
of Tiberius she had set her eye on the
highest prize succession to the throne
of emperor Tiberius went along with
these schemes though we don't know how
much of it he participated in
voluntarily in 12 BC Augustus agreed to
consider him a successor but only if
Tiberius would divorce his beloved wife
and marry Julia recently widowed
Tiberius was not happy about this pursed
lips Sonya was pregnant again and he
also knew of Julia's adulterous past
even Augustus knew of her adulterous
past heck all of Rome knew her
adulterous past surely men weren't
Saints either but you know double
standards hardly a recent invention
Julia in fact had even tried to seduce
time areas while she was still married
to his father-in-law Agrippa so yes this
makes Julia his step
mother-in-law trying to seduce him well
I guess we're just in full soap-opera
mode now the throne was the throne and
eventually Tiberius relented marrying
Julia neither of them was particularly
happy about the union but initially they
tried to make it work over time though
Tiberius began to Luther when their
first and only child died in infancy he
completely retreated from her
[Music]
Tiberius did more than just retreat he
went into a voluntary exile on the
islands of Rhodes in six BCE Julia went
on to have an affair with Mark Antony's
son and this was politically dangerous
eventually august's banished her from
Rome in two BCE the relationship with
Julia may have been the main reason for
his exile but even Suetonius is not sure
another theory is related to Augustus's
grandchildren gasps and Lucius
they had now come of age and Siberia's
did not want to stand in the way of
their lawful succession the implication
here is that he was a reluctant aspiring
Emperor to say the least
during his self-imposed time in Rhodes
Tiberius visited the sick worked as
magistrate and mingled with the locals
he also attended philosophy lectures and
debates which could occasionally get
loud and out of hands during one of
these debates he was accused by a
students of supporting one philosopher
over another instead of mounting a
well-reasoned comeback the normally
unflappable Tiberius went home only to
return with some gods he had the
loudmouth seized and sent to the jail
after the first few years of voluntary
exile Tiberius started regretting his
decision he longed to return home but
Augustus would not give his permission
slanderous rumors had started
circulating apparently the exile as he
was now known was plotting against the
Emperor eventually it was Gaius who
convinced his grandfather to yield and
Tiberius was allowed back home to Rome
into seee on one condition
Tiberius renounce all interest in
politics and lead and a political life
this would prove to be difficult being
barely set foot in Rome when Lucius
younger of the Emperor's has died of an
illness while traveling to Iberia a year
in half later the older Prince Gaius
died from wounds received in Armenia or
Gustus was now left with one male
descendant Agrippa posthumous youngest
son of Julia is still a boy four months
later
Augustus formally adopted Tiberius a
clear sign that Tiberius would be his
principal successor but for the moment
the Emperor had other plans Tiberius was
needed in Germany in the ensuing
campaigns the Valerius general Tiberius
quashed another rebellion then moved to
Bohemia Pannonia and Dalmatia to deal
with further interactions when he was
about to celebrate his well won triumph
snoozers reached
of the terrible catastrophe at the
Teutoburg forest in 9c II in which
Germanic tribes had annihilated the
three legions of general Varro Tiberius
returned to Germany for two more
expeditions alongside his nephew
Germanicus but Augustus had wisely
decided not to expand further into those
lands in the year 14c Tiberius was about
to depart but yet another campaign when
he was summoned by or Gustus the
terminally ill Emperor asked him not to
leave it was clear to type areas that
succession was around the corner
this was the moments that his mother
Livia had been waiting for
Augustus clearly valued Tiberius as
administrative and military skills yet
he disliked his dour somber character so
areas had a quiet inscrutable demeanor
but could unleash retribution when least
expected after their last meeting
August's gasped poor Rome doomed to be
masticated by those slow-moving jaws
when Augustus died apparently Tiberius
and Livia did not break the news
immediately this is disputed but Livia
may have ordered the assassination of
the young Agrippa the remaining living
grandson of Augustus according to this
version after Livia got rid of the
competition Tiberius summons of the
Senate and announced the death of the
Emperor this meeting was a strange
affair Tiberius started a speech but
could not go on claiming that grief had
robbed him of his voice and that he
wished his life would also be taken the
Senate then read or justices will in
which he made clear that Tiberius was
only his third choice of emperor behind
Gaius and Lucius when the Senate
formally asked him if he wanted to take
the mantle he visibly hesitated and
remained silent he did accept eventually
becoming the new emperor but leaving an
impression that he was doing so only
reluctantly this may be true after all
it was Olivia's main goal not his he had
proved to be more at ease with military
rather than civilian life and was framed
to seek isolation for long periods
according to other interpretations
Tiberius was just trying to emulate or
Gustus this is exactly what August's
would have done feint humility before
accepting the highest possible honors as
an emperor Tiberius his first act was to
rescind the allowance for his estranged
wife Julia the results were brutal
Julia died of malnutrition as a result
this was a typical example of tiberius
ability to exact cold and calculated
retribution on his enemies whenever he
needed to his first years in power
however was stable prosperous and
peaceful to Roman citizens this may have
been a consequence of Tiberius getting
rid of his rather scheming mother Livia
according to historian Cassius Dio Livia
did not miss a chance to declare that
she was who had made Tiberius Emperor
not only did she wish to rule in equal
terms with him that she wanted her
decisions do take precedence over his
tribe areas Seward once been a pawn in
her hands warns Livia not to interfere
in the running of the state removing her
from any public affairs he refrains from
having any future contact with her
Tiberius initiated a series of public
works while always keeping an eye on
expenses they tried to maintain a good
relationship with a Senate respecting
their authority but his colds and
impenetrable personality did not gain
him any friends and he became
increasingly unpopular his polar
opposite was his nephew Germanicus by
now his adopted son Jim Anika's was
popular well-liked and apparently would
have been the choice for Emperor in many
generals Minds Tiberius had reason to
fear a coup from Germanicus the young
officer however always voiced his
support of Tiberius
on the 10th of October Germanicus died
in Antioch after a brief illness his
body showed potential signs of poisoning
his wife was Agri Pina the elder who was
also a granddaughter of Augustus Agri
Pina immediately accused Tiberius of
having ordered the assassination of
Germanicus according to her Tiberius had
exploited the enmity between Germanicus
in Wonka næss piso a former governor of
Syria who had been ousted by the young
general Pisa was tired in Rome and
despite his appeals to Tiberius he was
forced to commit suicide
forced suicide was a form of capital
punishment sometimes used in Imperial
Rome another notable victim being
philosopher Seneca during Nero's reign
Agra Pina
was not satisfied with Peters execution
she made it clear to the Emperor that
with Germanicus dead her three sons nero
caesar Drusus caesar and Gaius Julius
Caesar also had a claim to the throne
treati character Tiberius did not react
initially even took a liking to the boys
but in Suetonius version of the events
he took action at a later stage if us
brought about all sorts of false charges
against the two eldest when they dared
complain he had the marked as public
enemies by the Senate this led to their
incarceration and eventual death
Nero was forced to commit suicide and
Drusus was stopped death the boy was so
hungry that he eventually started eating
as mattress of Germanic as the sons only
gas would survive and he was actually
welcomed into the various household guys
used to wear a miniature uniform while
on campaign with his father
hence the surname little boots or
Caligula we actually have a video about
him by the way so go and watch it later
just not quite yet there are some more
conspiracies coming the death of
Jamaica's brought a change to Tiberius
as personality according to Casillas do
he became increasingly cruel toward
those who were suspected of plotting
against him he was inexorable slaves
were tortured to make them testify
against their own masters Suetonius
agreed with the change of demeanour
Tiberius did so many other wicked deeds
under the pretext of reforming public
morals but in reality it was to gratify
his lust for seeing people suffer during
this period Tiberius became best buddies
with an officer of the Legion Lucius
alias say honest eventually he appointed
in prefect or commander of the
Praetorian Guard
this was the elite corps tasked with
protecting the Emperor and his family
say
as Gruen standing becoming the chief
advisor and confidant of Tiberius
Tiberius gradually withdrew from the
day-to-day running of the empire
delegating many decisions to see Ana's
sianis started seeing himself as the
next Emperor and began to view versus
son of Tiberius and the senior is a
natural rival in order to strike at him
say honest hit races where it hurt the
most he began to have an affair with his
wife Lavinia drusus died in 23c II by
poisoning it is very likely that he was
killed by si honest and Lavinia this was
not immediately evident though and the
grieving ty very has launched a harsh
investigation to find the culprits he
became so enraged and ruthless that
according to Suetonius he once mistook a
friendly visitor from Rhodes as a key
witness he had him seized interrogated
even tortured when it was clear that the
poor guy just popped in to say Ave
Tiberius had him executed to silence the
scandal by 25c say honest had grown the
strength of the Praetorian Guard to
twelve thousand men had golden statues
of him erected around Rome next he
embarked on a series of treason trials
to weed out any possible opposition by
this point many Romans they were living
in fear adalah Villiers in systems say
honest divorced his wife and left his
children the couple then appealed to
dive areas for permission to marry that
Tiberius denied the request Tiberius
grew more and more distant from the
affairs of the Empire as he had done
years before he decided to withdraw into
a second virtual ex arm this time moving
to the Isle of Capri in 26 sieep this
did not call his thirst for blood
according to Suetonius now I should
specify that Suetonius himself used as
sources the memoirs of Agri Pina the
younger who was she well she was the
daughter of Janaka so writings may have
kinda been anti Tiberius during the
years in Capri Tiberius had countless
alleged conspirators thrown to their
death from the rocks high above the sea
in one famous incidents a fisherman with
a huge mullet visited Tiberius not
talking about the hairstyle here rather
the fish he was bringing the fish as
present Tiberius was so scared and
paranoid that he ordered his guards to
rub the fisherman's face with the mullet
the scales skinned it roar in the poor
guy shouted thank heaven I did not bring
Caesar that huge crab I also caught
however though this was a mistake
because Tiberius then send for the
haven't had it used in the same way in
the year 29 news reached I've areas that
his mother Livia had died aged 86 she
had been suffering from a long illness
but Tiberius had never visited her even
in death he basically ignored her and
made no arrangements at all in her honor
except for the bare minimum a public
funeral which he did not attend this is
according to historian Tacitus another
guy we should also take come grano Salis
as he was staunchly pro senate and wary
of imperial power he wrote that Tiberius
excused himself from the funeral on the
ground of the pressure of business two
years later Caligula moved Capri to live
with Tiberius if the reports from our
ancient historians are true then we
could say that the future Mad ruler
Caligula may have learned a trick or two
from the Tiberius playbook of cruelty
but in some cases his ruthlessness may
have actually had a point in the same
year 31 CEC honest and Lavinia announced
their betrothal they would go ahead with
or without imperial permission live in
Lea's mother
Antonio Minor wrote Tiberius and
informed him that the lovebirds had a
plan to murder him and young Caligula
Tiberius rush back to Rome and appeared
before the Senate demanding that si
Ana's be subject to trial
sionis was lured to the Senate and
forced to answer to the accusations of
conspiracy to commit murder under the
Emperor's influence it was a swift trial
if the praetorian guard was found guilty
and condemned to death but not just any
death si honest was strangled and thrown
into an assembled mob who tore his limbs
apart and that his remains to the dogs
his sons and followers were also
executed Lavinia was also put to death
with what I now believe to be Tiberius
is favorite modus operandi starvation
her own mother Antonia made sure that
she did not eat anything
the reclusion of Tiberius in Capri
became a full-time status in his later
years now in his 70s an increasingly ill
he attempted to return to Rome only
twice after the trial of Si honest on
the first occasion he was traveling by
trireme up the Tiber but upon seeing the
city walls from a distance he ordered
the captain to return to Capri in the
second occasion he was traveling by
lands when he noticed that his pet snake
had been eaten alive by ants
interpreting this is an omen of mob
rebellion he retreated once again
Tiberius died on March the 16th in the
year 37 seee at the age of 77 in their
venomous I may have been poison
administered by a new Praetorian prefect
with help from Caligula upon hearing of
his death the Romans according to
Suetonius yelled to the Tiber with tiny
arias kasia's do in a more balanced
account simply wrote thus Tiberius who
possessed a great many virtues and great
many vices and followed each set in turn
as if the other did not exist passed
away in this fashion on the 26th day of
March about from getting the date ROM
Casius summarizes the lights and shadows
of the reign and personality of Tiberius
as we have seen today top areas had a
cold and calculating intellect he could
be a good leader of men in the field but
was often uneasy when it came to
networking with political class he
alternated periods of intense paranoid
and psychotic activity with total
withdrawal from society he was a puzzle
within a mystery to his contemporaries
but can we do something to better
understand him well two of his
successors Caligula and Claudius have
been analyzed and diagnosed as
potentially having bipolar disorder
Tiberius Caligula and Claudius were all
related having common ancestors in Libya
and Tiberius senior considering that
this disorder can be hereditary could it
be possible that also Tiberius had the
same affliction I won't offer any
conclusion here I'll just leave it up to
you in the comments so I really do hope
you enjoyed that video please do smash
that like button if you did and also
subscribe to this channel when your
subscribing hit the notification bell
also I've got another channel called
Geographics it's sort of like bio
graphics except instead of being about
people it's about places if you like
this sort of stuff please do check it
out and as always thank you for watching
[Music]